foreign
Lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or licensed professional
hello
[Music]
yeah isn't that crazy dude we were like
turning off at least a couple minutes
ago yeah and he was like I'm turning it
off I know and it was still on I know
I'm just like what it was crazy when you
get the hoodie yeah we started already
oh and then the timer wasn't set and oh
[ __ ] now Chris wasn't ready either so so
what turns out turns out I'm the only
real one do you know why big I had to
get up because it's cold because it's
cold and um and and and uh they because
the air was on for too long and they're
just chatting like we're not doing
they're chatting like we're not doing a
show it's [ __ ] ridiculous and it's
all good so I got my spin move
mentalities hoodie on there we go you do
and I'll probably get way too hot in one
minute and everybody's real curious why
why I'm not or I'm purple you know you
know so yeah what the [ __ ] you said and
the reason is is because it's a weekend
on weekends I take the day off oh okay
what we're doing take off from the
purple all right well the show recording
on a weekend so that's all that always
is that's all they need to know okay
recording it on a weekend but also got a
new casing it's purple so technically
what is the weekend but your phone's
doing business technically
never stop you know what I mean no but
always on the clock baby okay well see
what I'm doing yeah okay and guess what
Denver yeah that's terrible okay guess
what Denver I'll be there soon
crystallia.com go on over get your
tickets Denver Denver are coming out
Denver coming to you live Denver did it
Denver and then also there's no other
words yeah Tempe uh the whole tour is
Going Bonkers unbestankable and uh so go
to chrisley.com we added so many dates
it's [ __ ] ridiculous dates on dates
doing uh Midland Texas doing uh New York
you know doing New York doing Chicago we
added a show in San Diego you know so
it's like crazy how it's going Seattle
what the [ __ ] always doing Portland
it sounds crazy yeah so it's you know
Springfield wherever that is Missouri
not crazy that's crazy let me get the
orange coaster because I got orange on
and I got orange barrier I got an orange
area too thank you I'll use the blue one
all right it doesn't matter though it
does no I got green and orange that's
good because the Perry is green and
orange yeah but it would be cool if you
if you mismatched it I don't like to do
that oh you want that yeah well because
I have the green one okay see how good I
am of a brother yeah but it's not good I
don't like that I like when it's
different it's nicer no I used to like
give it back then oh sorry it's like
monochromatic and now I like my [ __ ] you
know popping into we go
in phases okay life is a series of
phases the worst philosopher and who we
are in one of those phases is not the
same as who we are in another one of
those phases and that raises the
question who are we Who Am I who are you
[Laughter]
uh and these are these are just the the
the musings of a uh you know regular old
uh
regular old guy
um you know what I was thinking about
just now when you were doing that yes I
spark thoughts often is when you're in
college uh
uh and can you just record the professor
with your phone like is that allowed
yeah I don't know and then also you can
just not go to class and have another
person recorded and then just airdrop it
to you oh for sure I mean I passed
classes in college I didn't even go to
because I just had I was able to go
online and see what the [ __ ] happened in
class oh wait but not because video
because of like uh what do you call
streaming uh no uh streaming no there
was like PowerPoints you could access
that he didn't during the class oh so it
was just like screenshots
why are you cutting me off when I'm just
telling you the thing that it is okay
it's a PowerPoint presentation that he
would use to guide each class and you
could click through it because he posted
it on the class website was it a video
no okay no it was called the origins of
Christianity
why did I take that class because I'm
smart no that's not why you took the
class it kind of is the class helped you
because I was smart enough to choose to
take it and then I got even smarter at
the end all right well watch
lifeline.com to get your spin move
mentality hoodies
yeah look how pimpin pimpin he is in
that
um I let's stop saying no I won't do it
also go to madelia.com for your uh
advice sessions Tuesdays and Thursdays
from 1 30 to 5 p.m Pacific Time booya
Booyah and Booyah okay you know where
I'm gonna be
not three different things
um Cheyenne I've never been to Cheyenne
Wyoming have you no but you sound like
Cheyenne that's what they do in Cheyenne
hey
so [ __ ]
dude I was always hunting I watched I
watched uh uh you know the show eraser
the show or the movie a grandma such a
grandma you know the program program
eraser
I love it at the same time you know
killing me I have it but but just
because our grandma used to say program
a lot of grandmas we used to watch
hunter in bed with our grandma and she
would call it we can't miss our program
so no but I'll get in bed with her it's
creepy uh no but we we would watch
Golden Girls and then Hunter would come
on right we would just happen to watch
Hunter but we were watching golden it
was Golden Girls and then empty nasty
and then oh yeah dude do you remember
how
um light that her top blanket was I
don't it was so crazy light like
lightweight yes it was actually there
were holes in it like it was like oh
so poor you know no but yeah and she
wasn't real maybe she was she wasn't
yeah she just probably hand made it
because she was so [ __ ] old you know
I don't know but uh I always thought
about that later on cool that's not
interesting so uh yeah no but uh what
are we talking about
um uh which is the Hunter and then uh
Golden Girls programs eraser you've been
already eraser he says you've been the
last that's the Arnold Schwarzenegger
that came out probably in 2001 or
something with Vanessa Williams with
James Khan don't know who directed it
embarrassed go ahead okay so no that's
okay you know and don't have to be
embarrassed because you don't know who
directed a racist guy and uh
so uh so there's a I watched eraser
reborn
it came out recently who's in it who
knows you said you saw it so you do
I have no idea what you were your eyes
were closed yeah what's it like this so
what I watched the show I have no idea
who the actors are is it a show or a
movie the movie it's a program why do
you keep saying show because because it
it doesn't [ __ ] matter you know
because it's so trash you want to know
about uh what distracted me just now
Anthony winning yeah
the guys one of our producers came and
fixed one of the cameras touched the
camera he was moving around it doesn't
matter though so it was it felt like
Christian Bale doing the thing where he
gets mad at the guy backstage
what the [ __ ] are you doing good for you
on a podcast I'm so Scottish made him so
Scottish
so anyway about a racer reborn go ahead
stop interrupting me with about the
[ __ ] eraser reborn you wanted to talk
about it I'm helping you I know you're
interrupting me talking about eraser
reborn I'm not doing [ __ ] that people
aren't even gonna [ __ ] know about
that's why you say Anthony made me mad
and then I gotta explain what happened
because it's happening off camera
read the cameras and it was pissing me
off you didn't need to help you know I
did need to help erased a reborn
all right so I I I I I don't think that
anybody should make a [ __ ] sequel 20
years later we've talked about this yep
okay so they did it they do it all the
time but they did it with a racer no
good it was it even a hit I don't know
it might it probably was it was yeah
that was when he was it was like mid 90s
when he was huge true no I think it was
2000 but no way dude there's no way
there is no way what year did eraser
come out
I was more right you said mid 90s
I'm more right
so um
so anyway I think you're thinking of the
sixth day no that was actually 2006 I
think anyway
um
so I'm watching a race for Reborn and I
tell you what man it's it's so bad yeah
I believe that it's so bad that even I
couldn't watch it and I don't know who
is in it the people in it are the most
like computer generated white guy Asian
girl and black dude let's look it up
look at the people in the reborn dude
the the white guy the Asian girl and the
black dude it's like they are all
amalgamations of different uh this is a
non by the way this TV is not so I'm
pissed yeah
and I'm just gonna show that yeah dude
so much shit's getting messed up
look at this
okay so what do I do dude
oh [ __ ] we got it so all right so listen
so look at the guys so bring up so first
of all they're all they're oh the names
are made up too it is like a CG [ __ ]
composite of different it's like AI made
these people yeah look at them look at
the first guy
sure would
the even their names are are okay yeah
but Jackie lay wow this is so [ __ ] Ai
and then the the black guy's the most AI
though generated Michael
number three
McKinley Belcher the third dude you know
what it's like the Japanese video games
that made the baseball thing that get it
wrong Mick Hunter you know chin stop the
Contour chin stop
McKinley Belcher three dude not three
the third but yeah yeah yeah well it's
it's a Trilogy Eddie Ramos okay mango no
but dude I mean I can't believe the
people Mambo Mambo Number Five yeah
Mambo Number Five breast yeah so um yeah
dude but I can't even believe it the
black dude in it in his head shot he has
his shirt no no no no no no and his head
he's taking his shirt off yeah yeah hey
dude hey hey like this like this we'll
change hurts let's change shirts for the
for the next look it goes like this wait
hold on take it
anyway dude eraser reborn it's on HBO
Max and it's so far I know so I stopped
watching that and then I started
watching jumper did you ever watch that
with Hayden Christensen no that looks
real bad okay but let me tell you
something it's not bad until the end and
then it's one of the worst movies of all
time ain't that a [ __ ] I hate movies
like that yeah so uh anyway I love Craig
Hayden Christensen though do you really
yeah I do I love him did you see
shattered glass no is he good in it he's
really good in that but you know who's
the best in that who is Peter sarsgaard
is that the one about the author yeah or
the the journalist yeah yeah okay who
made up all the lies oh I didn't know
about that yeah so um so anyway I hidden
Christian was at the Laugh Factory once
and he came up and he told me I did a
good job so I love him so there's
another example of Chris only caring
about people and liking them if they
like him first I am insecure wow I am
insecure I am insecure
I am insecure oh my God the Freaks Come
Out at Night Swimming I am insecure I am
insecure
insecure robot
no the insecure robot would be I
secure yeah yeah because you know he's
lying because he's insecure all right
got it I got it I got it yeah it's all
good so anyway
um all right do you want to go get into
the show or what oh yeah sure I mean we
talked about the hard-hitting issue we
talked about eraser reborn we talked
about shattered glass a little bit we
touched on Grandma Carmela's [ __ ]
small blanket and we talked about empty
nests so and we talked about how she
says program right so let's get to the
TV show what's Happening
uh
um yeah let's do it all right let's do
it
it's not playing
it went away
it's okay we can cut it out
oh it's gonna be so loud oh yeah I will
manage this it's gonna be so loud we
would just cut this out or we could
leave it you know it might be fun to
leave it it's not playing
it's okay it will guys relax we can cut
it out
um
getting raped
what did he say oh my God this needs to
stop
what is zoom room what is that what if
it kept on opening only fans and we
found out that Mako had like so many
subscriptions to only fans guys I
so it's fixed so
that was amazing
dude
let's cut it back let's cut it back in
now because this is so funny dude the
Purdue our producer Chris cannot get
okay we have to cut out a huge chunk
because we've been sitting here for like
seven minutes because he can't [ __ ]
he can't this [ __ ] goddamn what is it
Zoom room what is zoom zoom room I don't
know what that means uh it's not zoom
it's Zoom room and he can't get out of
it and it can't
and he'd he deleted it from his computer
and it's still open so let's play it
what we want now
is for it to be fixed and therefore it
is fixed
dude is it are we better be recording
this is amazing recording also turn the
stinking ass there turn the air off dude
he goes like this it keeps doing stuff
like so [ __ ] dude dude he's blind
curdling mad
so chill
I'm losing it
so the great thing is is that it it's
fixed because I want thing about right
now is that look at he's Googling Zoom
room
[Laughter]
look that was a commonly asked question
how come Zoom room keeps starting on its
own oh really yeah what the [ __ ] is zoom
rooms
oh
I can't wait till it's not better dude
all right play it okay play hit the
timer here we go here we go
hi guys
um I love the podcast cute makes me very
happy I think you'll like uh my advice
it'll open up a big a good conversation
I think great
um I've recently made friends with
somebody oh who
I bring her up
and she kind of brings me down like
she's kind of behind where I am in life
okay like she parties a lot more than me
and isn't as responsible
as I am like I just like to be
out of trouble a bit more these days but
I know that having me around is really
helpful for her
but I I'm starting to feel a little bit
drained by the Friendship so
how do you think I can still be a friend
but
have good boundaries in place
thanks
frankly it doesn't sound like you're
really getting much out of the
Friendship yourself it sounds like she's
getting all the goods and you ain't
getting [ __ ] uh which makes me want to
ask why are you friends with her but
since you're not here anymore I can't
ask you that uh I mean talking like the
bad guy in Matrix I'm not doing that
well it makes me want to ask why are you
friends with her but why why I mean like
we didn't get any reasons why and it
makes me wonder why you are like does
this woman have something hanging over
your head like a threat oh man like
Terence did with me in third grade or
first grade deeper
um does she have documents
pertaining to yeah I don't know um I I
she bring you know she brings you up and
you bring you bring her up and she
brings you down
I mean dude you know maybe just like
[ __ ] let her Reach Out do you my
question would be do you like hanging
out with exactly does it sound like you
know if you're getting if you're getting
enjoyment if it Sparks joy as Mary
Condon says or whatever the [ __ ] her
name is oh Marie kondo yeah yeah that's
different than me but yeah
is Marie straight to Compton married
condoms merry condoms that'd be a good
condom company
um
if you're if she's sparking Joy then you
know hang out if she's not then what are
you doing hanging out I think what you
should do
is either honestly not really be friends
with this person or say something just
be like look I feel like in our
relationship it's kind of like I'm
giving you much more than you're giving
me and like you kind of suck things dry
while I'm adding life to it like what do
you what do you do you also feel that
way like what's going on in the morning
and say suck things dry well why are you
making it [ __ ] sexual
[Laughter]
uh yeah I don't know I just it doesn't
sound like you're getting anything out
of the relationship
so I think stop being friends with this
woman that's what I think
he sucks you dry yeah you don't want to
say that and pinches your [ __ ]
nipples and okay tickles your butthole
wow you know so
worst [ __ ] therapist so uh yeah yeah
I think that you gotta there was either
she's you have fun hanging out with her
or you don't if you do talk to her if
you don't
Hit the Road Jack Hit the Road Jack
okay Hit the Road Jack don't you come
back no more no more no more you know no
okay
all right yeah dropper dropper well
that's my advice to you okay
next one
um I need some advice
dating and relationships oh yeah so cool
would you tell someone that you're
dating
non-exclusively but you were seeing
other people at the same time ooh and
how would you go about being honest
about that I'm seeing somebody that I
really like but it's not exclusive
and somebody else asked me out today and
I kind of want to tell this guy that I'm
seeing just to make him jealous okay
we'll talk to that I guess my question
is like is that okay to do to like I
mean tell a guy that you're seeing other
people with the intention to make him
jealous you know the answer or should I
just keep it to myself she's got three
dudes in the back seat right now that's
what she's seeing anyone else
they all got [ __ ] what do you guys
think it's a drunk so high at first I
was like yeah I just I was thinking like
yeah just tell them but then she
revealed her reason which is
specifically to make the guy jealous
which is a [ __ ] shitty thing to do
that shitty people do so if you're a
shitty person yeah do that let him know
you're shitty by doing that uh because
it's good to be honest if you're shitty
it's good to let him know but I would
suggest not being shitty and not trying
to make him or anyone jealous dude this
video could have been four seconds long
and it could have been this
um should I make someone feel awful
I mean like the context matters yeah
yeah it's just like you don't if if you
look the the game's the game all right
if you want to go and date another dude
then do that if you want to tell the
Dude tell the dude but if you're doing
it to make him jealous then that's like
why are you backing it up for this new
dude you know but what I think you
should do is be open and honest with
this dude and if you are seeing another
guy then you know it's okay to let him
know but also like
it mixed in the head if you want to make
her him jealous you want to know what I
think actually yeah what I think is
Doctor Strange what I think is
she wants him to be jealous because she
doesn't think he's into her she wants to
be with him so she wants to be exclusive
with him so how about this instead of
asking saying yes to that other guy and
telling your boyfriend about it say no
to the other guy and say hey this other
guy asked me out but I said no and guess
why because I want to be exclusive with
you yep and here's the best part if he
says no I don't want to be exclusive
with you then you can [ __ ] go date
whoever the [ __ ] you want yeah and it'll
be back to where you are right now but
you don't make yourself move three you
don't do something specifically to hurt
someone yeah that's not what people do
yeah just make your clam go from if you
go hey excuse me you know what I mean
I can't go out with you hold that
thought
hey I told a guy no
because
I I like you and I want to be excuses
with you don't want to be excused the
guy goes no then we take the clam we
move it back three feet what
is the clam
come on man the vagina yes if you want
to be clinical about it but what do you
mean you move it back three feet because
you well I mean that's a big big Rod but
you know maybe oh like his dick is three
feet all right I mean you're doing it
all wrong you're not cynical okay that's
why I didn't understand it though three
feet nobody Associates a dick with three
feet
it's so stupid to say it uh yeah so the
advice on the ground be different don't
be the exact opposite be the exact
opposite of what you are get scraped
shut the [ __ ] up top of it shut the [ __ ]
up okay it I'm just saying it get
scripted we heard you no no because
you'd think it was the bottom but it's
not because when I walk it goes like it
drags yeah and the kids at the top of
the head gets all Gravelly and [ __ ] up
okay now shut up don't be a shitty
person do the exact opposite of what you
asked us
if you should do or not okay bye yeah
look the best time to prepare for growth
is before the opportunity arrives did
you know that especially for online
businesses uh we have online business I
have an online business and uh we use
ship station and ship station is amazing
it sets you up for growth by directly
integrating with every shopping cart and
storefront so your products are easier
to find easier to manage and easier to
get into the hands of happy customers
quickly don't this is the problem don't
wait until you're drowning in orders to
find the shipping solution upgrade to
ship station today it's very good to do
now too before the holidays ship station
Keeps Us prepared uh for Lifeline drops
and uh the holiday season for Merch it
gets really hectic and that's where ship
station comes in and saves the day so
get these same discounted shipping rates
as Fortune 500 companies you ever heard
of them or you live under a rock uh
whether you're sending a stack or a
truck full uh so that's over 130 000
companies who have grown their
e-commerce business with ship station so
you know what don't be left out ship
more and grow more with ship station go
to shipstation.com today and sign up
with promo code Lifeline for a free
60-day trial that's two months okay
start today and get set up before the
biggest shipping season of the year
that's two months free visit
shiftstation.com clip the microphone at
the top and type in code Lifeline do it
Matt and Chris love the dynamic of how
much Matt cringes at everything Chris
does ah falling good timing I need
advice I've been with my girlfriend for
a little while now and mostly it's good
but literally every big event her
birthday Friend's Wedding my birthday
anniversary Etc becomes a huge fight
about what our relationship is or isn't
we will be having the best time and I'll
go all out for her getting a cabin with
her closest friends flowers fancy
restaurant name it oh my God we've only
been dating about a year and a few
months that's you shouldn't use the word
only because that's a long time live
together now for about six months
otherwise our relationship is generally
good but these fights when we're
supposed to be having our best times and
making memories have put a huge doubt in
pursuing a lifetime with her if I can't
enjoy life's important moments with
arguments I'm not sure that I can enjoy
life with her uh your advice would be
greatly appreciated my first piece of
advice is to use your and your and
separate them because you said you are
advice instead of your advice maybe
that's now you're acting like his
girlfriend right yeah but this isn't a
special moment this is just well it I
mean he's on Lifeline I have experience
in this like I've I dated someone once
that every time it was long distance and
every time we were about to see each
other again
we would we would get into like this
biggest fight about the smallest
non-thing that's so common yeah it is
common I think this is sort of like it's
not the same thing but it's generally on
the same wavelength I don't know what
the [ __ ] that is but I don't think it's
like
uh I don't know I mean some I think
usually what that is is a sign of like
incompatibility in general I guess so
but you it's so easy not to argue when
you're just chilling yeah exactly and
when the second something comes up then
it's like it's like you guys are like
this and the second somebody's like
let's go to the park it's like
oh [ __ ] and then it's harder to get back
on and it [ __ ] and before you know it
you're like where's the [ __ ] where's
the you know yeah and she's like I told
I didn't yeah you're [ __ ] I think the
fights start to arise when expectation
starts to creep in and that's why
expectations are no good for anybody
because people start to expect things
and then when that expectation is not
met they get angry and then they bring
up the partner bring it up with the
partners if it's their fault the partner
gets mad for having expectations put on
them that are unfair blah blah blah blah
and so on and so forth the bottom line
is
stop stop
expecting things tell people what you
want so you don't have to expect they'll
just be able to give it to you you know
what I mean I I understand yeah uh and
so tell her maybe instead of having an
expectation about your birthday or your
friend's wedding tell me how you think
it should go beforehand and then we can
just do it that way yeah it's still
tough I mean look here's yeah it's not
that easy if you're if you're arguing
and it's tough uh a year and six months
in and if it's been happening for a bit
and it's happening every time you're
doing some [ __ ]
it's tough if you're five six years in
something like that sleeper then it's
it's a little different because you've
been together for longer but like if
it's all you're you're in your you're in
your honeymoon phase like this is
something that shouldn't be happening so
so much now at this point so it is a red
flag but also
I don't know man are are you doing stuff
like getting a cab and going to a fancy
restaurant getting flowers together and
doing all this [ __ ] because you are like
running from something you know what I
mean in which case that could be
something within you that you got to
look at I don't know the whole thing
kind of sniffs of a red flag to me and
I mean how huge are these fights too are
they like big blowout fights because
couples fight in fact when couples don't
fight at all that's a sign that
something's really wrong or or
it's perfect
let's not forget that I still think
every couple should have at least one
fight a year just to keep it right
you're right you know so we're gonna
fight about uh yeah oh honey we haven't
had a fight in 11 months we should get
to it yeah it's last May yeah September
um I just think like go [ __ ] yourself
you're not gonna have you're not gonna
find someone that you've never fight
with if it's a good relationship so if
it's really all the [ __ ] time every
single time there's some big event
something looked exciting about looking
forward to something that's supposed to
be fun and she or you always turn it
into [ __ ] in one way or another yeah I'd
say that's nothing worth looking at
fight once a year at least once a year
but right but he's already fought many
many many times in a year and a half so
you bought yourself some years of not
fighting so maybe be single and don't so
stupid so stupid I'm just saying
um up sweetie but yeah I mean we haven't
argued since last June uh and it is
October your dad's annoying I agree that
if you can't enjoy life's moments
without arguments okay like then break
up with her right yes but like if you
love her and really want to make the
relationship work figure out a way to
get [ __ ] things therapy also you know
I thought of you are all right
betterhelp.com
laying down just woke up need your help
with something so I started talking to
this girl a couple weeks ago
everything's going great she's super hot
um has a good job fun to be around not
his hand really nice
um the only downfall is she has a dog
that she treats like a human
um literally so she takes showers with
the dog oh she talks to it like it's a
person
um she has it like sit down at the table
with her and oh what food he drinks
water out of cups it goes as a job it
dictates her everything it's a pilot
um
and yeah I've never seen anything like
it and I've had pets my entire life so
it's a little weird
um is it maybe because she just has like
good motherly instincts and she yeah on
this dog
it's a deeper but I don't know let me
know what you guys think should I just
do a spin move should I try to talk to
her I don't know
I mean people are really sensitive about
their pets so when you do bring it up
don't be like what the [ __ ] is up with
you and the dog I know what to do this
is the opposite of that bring it up but
bring it up real careful and do it as if
you're just curious and don't say hey
I'm just curious but embody just
curiosity that's the only way you'll be
able to get answers and then be careful
along the way baby step baby step baby
step and maybe you'll get some kind of
color on why the [ __ ] she acts like that
but showering with a dog and having a
dog sit with you at the dinner table is
very very strange get a donkey and do
the same thing she does and one-up her
just it donkey in the passenger seat
just while he's driving
wearing a [ __ ] like a a
um what do you call it a uh
uh Patagonia like a like a person thing
like it's a human yeah shorts on it and
and like Jordans and then like having it
get out of the car just like just
[ __ ] [ __ ] the car up and [ __ ] and
then like having it sit in the passenger
seat and you're in the back and she's
driving and [ __ ] up her car and
[ __ ] all over her passenger seat and
and also like [ __ ] the dog up a
little bit like with this and then it'd
be like I'm sorry they're just in a
fight like you have to like they have to
let them figure it out and she's like
but on the second she says but it's a
donkey and then say so we agree then
right okay well don't do that yeah
because the dog is a dog and the
donkey's a donkey but but to do that
you'd have to have a donkey yeah get a
dog
Thanksgiving just sitting there giving
it a knife and a [ __ ] right
with the turkey just
killing your uncle and [ __ ] you can't
have a donkey and then just go oh so we
agree take a show shotgun boom with the
donkey and then boom with the dog oh my
God you make a great point though no no
no no donkey you can get a donkey for a
thousand five hundred dollars that's too
much effort that's a cute donkey you can
get a donkey for a thousand five hundred
dollars I think it's great a great idea
uh okay so I think cheaper than that
purebred dogs a lot of people are crazy
about their pets that is a bit above and
beyond but yeah I think all you need are
answers her answers might make it sound
and seem a little bit better it also
asking about it might at least open the
door for you to be like well maybe like
maybe not like at the dinner table like
some kind of compromise but it's just
the donkeys no it's about her and her
dog only there's no donkey
but if she gets really really defensive
about it that is a huge red flag that is
not a situation worth being in if she's
open to it and like
listening and kind of takes your
concerns into account yeah
if you have this conversation with her
and she says well let me see how my dog
feels then you gotta go yeah right
that's a bad let me ask my dog about it
all right so yeah that's that's a weird
thing that [ __ ] people do yeah it is
weird usually they're old people and
really lonely well more chicks it's
mostly women or gays that do that but
yeah no straight dude does that so I bet
they do yeah I know but I'm generalizing
so anyway
wow dude a tree that guy
he's [ __ ] in uh what's the Harry
Potter for sure all right next one
yo what's up Chris what's up M diesel
what's up hopefully got an easy one here
for you
uh so I'm not much of a drinker
but I do like to go out and socialize
when opportunity presents itself with
co-workers and friends and whatnot uh
however I have a hard time figuring out
what I want to order uh because I don't
have a taste for it uh I don't drink a
lot
um so if you guys throw me some
suggestions uh I know Matt probably your
uh better at giving some suggestions uh
but also Chris
um like if I don't want to drink how do
you how do you go about that situation
how do you approach that and like
um without
getting the attention on yourself and um
kind of slowing down the momentum of the
the social
uh Gathering uh sweet
um super excited for the confused
podcast coming out can't wait to see
that
and thanks for the advice dude I always
would it's so because I don't drink and
like it would be so annoying when I was
sitting there nothing and be like why
aren't you drinking so I would just get
a sometimes get a club soda but then I
would I would often tell them can you
put it in a [ __ ] glass like that
would I'd get like club soda because
it's so annoying people like you're not
drink and you gotta explain you dude
you're doing this like nine times a
night so I get one of those little mini
straws that they have and a [ __ ] lime
with the club soda so nobody would ask
me [ __ ] yeah that's good actually I
don't drink now I used to drink like a
[ __ ] fish but I don't anymore and I
never even thought about that I just say
what I actually say is now it's okay I
don't drink uh and then they and then
they look at you a certain way and then
and then you I immediately say yeah I'm
no I'm not like sober I just I just
don't drink because they always assume
like oh like are you an alcoholic yeah
and that's obviously not the case with
you it wasn't the case with me either I
just I don't know I lost my case for it
somehow
um but also if you do want to get a
drink that you can nurse and not get
[ __ ] up on I mean definitely beer is
the way to go everything else you can't
really manage or or you won't know a
beer along Atlantic City really yeah no
no Long Island no Long Island Iced Teas
for you those will [ __ ] you up
immediately but um
beer beer or yeah do the thing that's a
good idea I never really thought really
yeah yeah no I that's so much better
they put my [ __ ] so annoying people
ask you that [ __ ] oh that's and then you
tell them you don't you don't drink
they're like you know what that's really
cool I really respect that right what
that's not why I'm doing it [ __ ] yeah
um thanks someone the uh get a Coke make
it look like rum and coke get a soda
make it look like vodka and soda uh uh
get it just honestly go like this do you
guys have root beer floats and when they
say [ __ ] this and leave I mean that
would as he said ruin the social
Gathering though yeah it'll be funny wow
I don't know man I don't know he'd be
alone at home after that if that
happened okay drinking a root beer float
not if they didn't have it but if
they're good he could go to like Summit
a diner afterwards yeah okay that's more
fun anyway man I mean all right though
he wants to hang with his [ __ ]
friends and they're all hanging at the
place maybe he doesn't dude he said he
does how about suggest other things
change the whole [ __ ] thing of advice
okay that's my minded you can do it one
person may not be able to change the
world but it can spark the idea that
does I mean Tupac said that okay okay
something like that okay it doesn't
matter though
uh
uh okay my advice was good yours was too
until you did it all [ __ ] up all right
next one I still like my donkey one
hey Chris hey Pastor M diesel uh loving
podcast by the way what's going on so I
have this I have a bad habit of biting
my fingernails
um I have for like since since I was a
kid I've been doing this and it's it's
just a gross habit the most regular
shirt I've ever seen um I'm trying to
stop
whenever you're like I'm shaking
somebody's hand it's just I'm
self-conscious and I'm always like
hiding my hands because they're just
crazy there you know um so yeah nice
ones smaller habits like this because
I'm like I'm not like an alcoholic but
it's it is affecting my life like it is
an annoying problem
um so just any advice on
maybe how to cope with it stop it
completely we're glad to help thank you
guys you wear gloves dip your fingers in
like [ __ ] your anus awful vinegar and
then stick them in the ground
before you leave the house go to no go
to the zoo say where are the rhinos and
then go find where the Rhinos or the
hippos are and then stick your hands in
their anus
you might get pink eye but you will not
eat your [ __ ] nails and also if he's
not touching his face he won't right
right well yeah but he'd be just like
this walking around and people be like
ew why does it smell like Rhino [ __ ]
yeah
um I think you should uh wear gloves for
real get gloves get those [ __ ] um
what do you call them those gloves where
the the rubber gloves that like uh yeah
yeah and people will because then it's a
two kind of twofold it's like you'll
your fingernails will get better you'll
get better with your habit and then also
people will think that you're very
important yeah people think you like
make a lot of money yeah yeah oh what's
going on there what do you gotta do be
like oh it just came from work and but
they you don't have to maybe work in
Crate and Barrel but it doesn't matter
they don't need to know they'd be like
oh he's a dentist why don't you take
those off and be like [ __ ] silly me I
think actually it might be cool if you
put like something on the insides of
your fingertips that not everybody could
necessarily see but you could feel it
and so like when you're about to bite
your fingernails you're just like maybe
remind yourself to do this it doesn't
work and it always looks like you want
to make money
and you and you go to uh uh I was in
therapy uh actually a long time ago uh
first round
yeah
and uh she said just put your finger on
it and hold it and and you might get
might get it better and it didn't work
so there's a thing on Shark Tank where
the guy was like hi sharks I have a
thing where if you bite your nails you
get like shocked a little bit and they
were like are you [ __ ] kid dude it's
a Shark Tank Episode and the guy's like
you can't sell this right yeah he's like
well it's a low-grade shock like for
dogs and then they were like and then
they're like well who shocks you and
then they were like you do so he's like
if you go you go oh hey what yeah that's
the worst [ __ ] product it actually
wasn't if you've ever seen that show
there are tremendously bad products so
worse than that that seems like as bad
as an idea because it's pretty bad yeah
it's pretty bad
um wear gloves that's my [ __ ] thing
wear gloves some kind of reminder that
only you can be reminded by you know
whoa a song a song
all right uh no yeah we're gloves okay
cool or or or wear one of those [ __ ]
uh what are the what's the uh Silence of
the Lamb's masks
uh yeah any mask yeah covered mask or
like the black death masks with the big
nose
right and you just still do it if you're
that dedicated because you're sucking
your thumb under that big dick nose but
at least it will be a reminder as you're
doing this you'd be like oh eight that's
right this mask yeah yeah okay all right
next
it makes me smile and uh it's kind of
serious at the same time uh so I'm
Barney I'm from Hungary and I have this
thing about not picking up the phone I
know it was a topic before but I'm on
the other side I'm the one not picking
up the phone because it gives me anxiety
and I don't know why I don't know what's
going on since the pandemic is
accelerated so I don't know what to do
because I'm losing friends over this oh
wow I tried to talk to them and they
don't really understand me I mean I
don't even know what's going on but
they're my friends they supposed to back
me up all right so it's just like
texting is all right because I can write
back whenever I feel it's okay to write
back yeah but when I'm writing back they
try to call me that's annoying problem
guys
so I'm losing friends over this and I
don't know what to do guys if you have
any advice just just uh I don't know
maybe fake John Lennon quotes or
variations of me moves or mats any
serious thing
uh just I don't know I'll just cheer me
up because I mean a really bad ad space
right now and I don't know what to do
thanks guys what a borrow well you can't
uh how bad could it be yeah yeah that's
kind of weird that your friends are
giving you that much [ __ ] over it okay
what the [ __ ] spin moves don't work here
because you're not even with them but uh
why don't you try starting with the
voice memo thing oh you just go hey
what's up guys baby steps so insecure ah
no I think uh that why are your friends
pushing at that that's my question yeah
because it's like they're they're trying
to upset you or something that's not
cool
like like I'm gonna get him but I can't
imagine I can't imagine someone just
being like he doesn't pick up the phone
enough yeah he texts me back but he
doesn't pick up the phone enough so I
don't want to be his friend or like it's
a fact I don't understand that's so
weird of your friends I'm like that and
my friends no that like I don't pick up
the phone and they're like oh that's how
Matt is that's how your friends are
supposed to be my friends call me I
cancel it and then text them and say no
text it well that's [ __ ] rude I don't
do that I just don't pick up the phone
or call anyone back I text him I suffer
from the realness but what you want out
of a friend is the friend to be like uh
well that's just who he is it's annoying
but [ __ ] haha it's kind of funny
because it's not a big deal it's not a
big deal it's not at all it's not so if
this is a big deal and if you're friends
no look I will say though
something seems weird if your friends if
there's multiple friendships that are
like have a problem with this then maybe
there's something that you're not
thinking about that you're doing that's
affecting this because the common
denominator is you in this situation but
if it's just about not picking up the
phone and you are texting back and
you're you know then it's kind of you
know it's kind of an it's that's weird
for them dude it's weird for them but
also like
maybe you could a little bit pick up the
[ __ ] like if you're actually losing
friends that you like because of this
maybe like give a little bit and if
you're gonna expect them to give a
little bit understanding you maybe you
give a little bit and uh
maybe that'll like absolve you in their
eyes or take a Xanax and say call me in
five oh you know what I mean yeah yeah
just don't take all the medications Matt
took on that plane don't take don't take
three and then get on a plane did you
pick up the phone you'd be like
damn
where the [ __ ] what was it you pick
up the phone don't go
to her don't call me as you pick it up
yeah nice okay cool it all comes full
circle yeah dude that's rough though man
and I'm sorry and I hope we cheered you
up and uh I don't know where you're from
it's he's from Bulgaria but where's he
living with the accident South African
to me yeah well yeah maybe yeah all
right
so next one what's up guys
um I love y'all's podcast thank you all
for doing this y'all give some really
great advice
um so I'm really hoping that maybe y'all
could help me out a little bit okay
um I'm a woman and a manly
and a mainly male dominated industry
um I've been doing this for well over
five years I've been with the same
company since the beginning they've
taught me everything I know and I'd say
I'm fairly good at it recently my boss
hired this guy and he has got over 20
years of experience he claims and he has
just come in and completely
derailed everything he comes in and he
goes behind me
um he goes and tells my boss what time I
show up to work what time I leave geez
um and it's just caused a lot of trouble
and he's only been with us for a couple
months he's taking the reins a lot over
these jobs and
I know it's not my place I'm not the
boss but I am a worker and I do I do
good work I think I deserve a little bit
of respect so what do y'all think
I should do about that sounds like
is it did you speed that up or did she
speak she's put it up I think
um uh she uh it sounds I don't I don't
jump to this conclusion ever but it
sounds like it might be a chauvinistic
thing you think yeah yeah but that's
what she's getting at she's saying how
do I deal with that though oh I didn't
say that no did she say specifically
what industry I missed that just that
it's mailed on it okay because obviously
I think that maybe she works just
without the thing is if it is a
chauvinistic thing he would be defensive
about being called out for that yeah so
I think that what you should maybe do is
just like have a sit down with him but a
casual one not like a hand to talk to
you be like you know I like dress
appropriately I've been doing this for a
while like I I know how this goes like
you can give me more responsibility than
I think you think I might be able to
handle uh like if you haven't said
anything start out
by making it sound like you're giving
them the benefit of the doubt so he
doesn't seems like I feel like yeah
exactly you know so he doesn't have to
get all [ __ ] defensive and be like
well I have 20 years you know I mean
yeah uh because you know how people get
yeah when they get told that they're not
doing things right at the workplace
especially if they have a lot of
experience they get so [ __ ] defensive
um but yeah start out that way and if it
continues or gets worse
it might be the it might be the kind of
thing you have to go to the boss also is
he above you
it sounds like he's come in and taken a
position of a little bit above her
higher than her yeah because that's
annoying but
yeah it's like the guy sounds like a
[ __ ] tattletail though dude yeah
that's the shoes if you're a good worker
and okay you leave early or get in late
and but you're [ __ ] killing it and
firing on all cylinders and nothing's
changed the only thing that changes that
he's here right right we've always done
it like that and you've been with the
company for five six years she said
right something like that so it's like
[ __ ] this guy dude yeah I [ __ ] can't
stand these [ __ ] man like the
title aspect is crazy but dude he also
like do your job right and if his job
was to come in and figure out where the
problems with the company is yeah it
sounds like it's not you it sounds like
it's not you uh I know that we're just
hearing your side of the story but
that's what why he was hired though okay
but that's what I'm saying but it might
be but if it wasn't okay then like if
you came into [ __ ]
be like I need to find out who the weak
links are we need to get rid of them
then okay but beyond your best behavior
but obviously she simply she would be so
dude uh the guy's a tattletail he's
chauvinistic and it's [ __ ] and say
why don't you do this with Frank
maybe he does do it with Frank though
well if he doesn't it's not a sexist
thing it's still a shitty thing though
it's a shitty thing it's just a little
tattletale yeah he's still a tattle Tony
still like a nitpicky [ __ ] yeah
whether it's chauvinism or not it still
sucks yeah I'm saying yeah right right
it sucks whether it's chauvinism or not
yeah yeah bring it up in like a in a
casual setting and make sure even though
it's annoying make sure
it doesn't he has no way of thinking it
comes off as like
any version of like a planey or or yeah
but you don't want to jump to HR right
no you don't want to jump to HR that's
what I'm saying the first thing you do
yeah is just offer the fact that you've
been there a while you know the ropes
and you can handle a lot of
responsibility yeah uh and you've been
there a while you have your own habits
like
you would think that that would be okay
I've been here for a long time everyone
knows the way I work everyone's okay
with it as long as it's okay with you I
think I'm going to continue to do that
yeah also he's been uh he has 20 years
experience and you have but but he
doesn't have 20 years experience of that
place you're at that place longer than
him so you have that under your belt too
yeah true yeah or in your skirt whatever
I'm just trying to be on his level you
know what I mean chauvinism wow but I'm
not being shown but it's funny and in
doing so you're being stupid well it's a
joke it's a comedy podcast so all right
that sucks though but yeah that does
suck
a guy that would be in CSI
okay what's up Chris and Matt uh so
today I have a mental health uh question
so I'm an actor here based out of
Atlanta I'm 24 I've been committing to
this for like five ish years now cool
and I've been watching my friends
graduate college the past few years and
now they have their big boy jobs and
they're all comfy and set right uh I've
also been watching friends like in the
business kind of like really grow and um
some of them made it right out of high
school and you kind of really don't know
the same struggles and I'm trying not to
compare myself to other people much
easier said than done yeah uh so what
are some of the things that you kind of
did in your earlier days to like power
through like the struggle phase and like
the the lows
because honestly it's becoming really
mentally heavy and it's hard not to feel
like a loser and um I know 24 is like
young in the eyes of oh guys 24. the
majority so you feel like I haven't
accomplished enough in like
I'm yeah it's it's heavy uh lately so
please uh let me know uh some things I
can do to kind of power through and keep
myself like in a good mental check
uh yeah thanks all right you're for 24.
first of all second of all you look like
an actor I was the one before you
started talking I said hey you would be
in CSI yeah uh you know he calls it
[ __ ] amazing I don't want to make it
about me but I called it it's funny and
you didn't want to make it about you but
you did so remember when I was like this
guy's British and he was like oh I was
going on yeah but what I'm saying is
dude 24 is nothing and I know that's so
annoying because I was 24 and I was I
was in the same situation dude all of my
friends were on TV shows they were all
bigger than me
okay okay
now look at you no I I don't but I I
just want to be like a decade what I was
gonna say right but a decade later yeah
yeah but what I was gonna say and they'd
have different they're not even actors
uh
oh one way to make yourself unhappy in
any profession it doesn't matter what it
is but especially some kind of any
version of the Arts or you know TV
whatever the [ __ ] acting
is to [ __ ] compare yourself to people
that are your age comparison is the
thief of Joy I don't remember who said
it it was probably a lady that has like
a [ __ ] YouTube channel but she was
right well it's true comparison does
take away all joy but what what you're
not realizing when you compare you're
only comparing yourself to people that
are more successful you're not taking
into account the [ __ ] billions of
[ __ ] who are less successful
than you it was Theodore Roosevelt who
said that uh and a lady from YouTube we
had a YouTube channel obviously stole it
from theater Roosevelt and I don't think
that's cool to do to Teddy but if you
um yeah don't compare yourself try it's
so [ __ ] hard dude it's so hard
with Jesus Christ all the time and it's
misleading it's unfair to yourself
because it's misleading you're only
taking into account the [ __ ] tiny
sample full of people who happen to be
more successful I know I know that's
true you're doing fine take into account
the here's what you should do watch go
on YouTube and watch short films made by
people that are generally your age it
will be astonished at how shitty they
are how much worse off than you they are
and you will [ __ ] feel better to know
that that is the vast majority of people
will be hilarious if you had a YouTube
uh short on YouTube you know look you
might as you might very well be one of
those people if you are I'm sorry but
I don't know I don't know what to tell
you um
but my point is uh yeah don't compare
yourself I know he but he knows not to
compare himself he said it right he was
like I don't mean to compare me I try
not to prepare myself but um but don't
because it requires action you have to
look up people to compare yourself yeah
true true
stop doing that it's like going on yeah
bump on your neck get offline you're an
actor focus on your I hate when people
say this but craft and then also you can
take things into your
uh you could take thing you can what am
I trying to say take things into your uh
you could take you could take control of
your situation yes you can you don't
it only it used to be about getting on a
show getting on a [ __ ] getting on CSI
getting on a sitcom getting on a [ __ ]
show on HBO it's not anymore you could
make your [ __ ] happen you could create
you can either write something or get
somebody who you could partner with that
it wants to write in the same situation
that you're in get together in Atlanta
and write some [ __ ] cool [ __ ] and
post something right I mean good then
you're kind of doing what Matt said but
don't make it shitty but don't be shitty
yeah don't be shitty about it but make
it come from your truth I get it trust
me I get it dude all of my friends were
successful before me man and you know
another container it's like they'll have
different jobs but it's not and I'm not
even trying to compare it don't compare
yourself obviously when you're on the
[ __ ] also as well right yeah don't
ever complain don't ever compare
yourself right yeah but but my point is
um
it'll happen just keep going and dad
always used to say this uh it's not
going to happen the way you think it is
but it'll happen yeah and
um and it will do just keep going man
the frustrating thing about being an
actor or anything in that industry in
our industry is that is that there's no
ladder that is established right to
reach success you talk about people in
business yeah people uh in healthcare in
most professions there is a
well-established road to get to where
people want to go uh as they progress in
their career it is not true as an actor
or any other thing in the Arts you can
[ __ ] at 48 get your first big break
and become a huge [ __ ] actor it's
actually that has literally happened
like there's there are all different
kinds of career paths and that is both
the worst thing about doing what people
like you do and also the best thing
because the it's the worst thing in the
way that God damn it could take until
you're [ __ ] 48 to get your big break
but you could also be the one
[ __ ] who had 47 and nothing
going on in that 48 you [ __ ] hit it
big and you've got the best [ __ ]
career you could have possibly imagined
there's no way of knowing and it'll be
that much sweeter than it'll just dude
just keep going man you're 24. it's two
it's too early just 24 years your baby
be upset and get it again you know this
guy's still got baby powder on his
[ __ ] ass you know this guy's still
drooling all over his bib and his
mommy's [ __ ] taking it off and
cleaning it a little a little bit but
yeah this guy's still [ __ ] has no
[ __ ] pubic hair you know check your
belly button do you have an umbilical
cord coming out this guy literally still
has no pubic hair I think none that's I
I
would argue he probably has pubic hair
you saw his eyebrows it literally hasn't
gone through puberty at all he
definitely has it because it looks like
two caterpillars are meeting epic area
is as hairless as is [ __ ] behind Okay
okay it looks like two caterpillars are
meeting at the forehead Cafe
he also he also had the beard that looks
like it like he actually has five
o'clock shadow yeah yeah [ __ ]
actually has to stay every morning
because like he's got a full beard yeah
yeah yeah it always looks like someone's
walking in front of him like that's how
much it he he needs to shave like he's
like why is it dark on your face okay
um so anyway maybe it's the shadow of
the [ __ ] caterpillars the shadow of
the caterpillars poetry I know us
I was just gonna say a movie with
[ __ ] Ashley Judd and Morgan Freeman
the shadow of the caterpillars [ __ ]
when they meet on the forehead Cafe that
means you're in trouble maybe they'll
shoot it in Atlanta and he'll get a
[ __ ] roll in it make a short film The
Shadow
of the four the shadow what is it the
shadow of the caterpillars and have it
be about a serial killer who has the
biggest [ __ ] eyebrows that cast a
shadow over his face and they look like
caterpillars and be the lead role I
always get to my destiny my eyebrows
always get to the destination two
minutes before me
have a roll like that you know the
caterpillars want revenge wow after this
coffee at the forehead Cafe worst
[ __ ] plot of all time like what are
you even saying you know
what's happening those are the
caterpillars
ew no no you do not make that sound
they're drinking the cat I don't give a
[ __ ] what they're doing I do not accept
that sound
one please
thank you look uh well uh we're gonna
think about it uh we'll we'll get back
to you thank you I'm school thanks for
coming in okay life's cool I look and
they just go
um all right cool would we have one more
or what okay
hey man Chris uh my name is Kate I'm a
long time fan
um I'm gonna try to be quick because I
keep exceeding the limit so my question
is about my marriage
um I've been married for seven no nine
years this is John Cusack together about
17 years
um my marriage is
great it's good it's really good I
married a really good guy uh we have
three kids
um but my question is about my husband
like isn't able to open up to me he's
not very
um emotionally literate he doesn't
really have feelings he doesn't share
feelings he doesn't shared Thoughts with
me
um Beyond like day to day like
kind of basic stuff
I tried to get into therapy and he
refuses like flat out that is his worst
nightmare um so I started therapy on my
own and it's life-changing
um Chris I'm kind of interested to hear
your thoughts knowing how you have
transformed over the past few years
um
so my question is how do I get him to
open up
do I push him into therapy hmm
how do I get them to open up in the
meantime how do I get him to be more
like just more connected to me
um
thanks so much that's so interesting man
like you know join the [ __ ] club
that's like the prime woman's complaint
I know about men oh man and it's true
men are just like you know how ask a man
how his day was he'll be like I don't
know it's good yeah how her day was you
just [ __ ] watch the clocks
wow so high energy dude [ __ ]
how was your day and
the [ __ ] I mean
people walking by oh God oh God these
holes are coming yeah all right right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah dude it's so
and I'll tell you what dude I here's
what [ __ ] came up for me and then
we'll get to you but man I'm like I open
up so much I open up so much therapy
everywhere Chris with Chris obviously
well for her like with my wife I open up
so much like she'll be like how do you
feel about this and I go like this I
take a beat I'm like Justin Trudeau when
he was asking questions by the reporter
and people like oh he didn't have an
answer but he was taking a beat dude you
know and so then I [ __ ] start talking
and [ __ ] we have conversations and it's
like I'm not saying I I deserve a medal
but dude I need to show her this but was
it always like that
Chris
was it always like that
I'm saying you gotta you gotta get to
the place as a man that you cut that you
understand the value
the value of why the value of opening
them up yes men don't intrinsically know
that women do right so men have to learn
the lesson of why it's valuable uh and I
think I I mean don't strong over strong
arm him into therapy but you can you can
kind of like softly put your foot down
about it someone did that for me once
and it's like you know that relationship
was a [ __ ] disaster but the one good
thing I got out of is that she actually
did make me go to therapy you know yeah
I think if it's the kind of thing where
you think it's affecting your marriage
and you're you've grown into this uh
person that it's important to I think
it's worth saying like you know don't
give him an ultimatum like oh you're
either gonna do therapy or I'm out but
you should Express to him how important
it is for you to it for him to at least
try it you know what I mean because
especially his aversion to it is a
little bit I don't want to say it's not
alarming I mean look the guy probably
thinks his life is fine and it's going
good he's got a great life but he might
benefit from it yeah it also though like
if he's got some try I have no idea what
his F who this guy is but like you know
he's probably pretty level-headed you
seem level-headed but like you know he
might be trying to not want to talk
about some stuff and not even know about
it like he might sit down at therapy and
she might be like at the first session
you'd be like so how are you and he just
goes [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah just for frying barbells
you know what I mean in slow motion just
Crystal [ __ ] like
right do you know what I'm saying and
then just crying so hard yeah and like
some people don't want to confront that
trauma yeah right A lot of people don't
and and I don't even think that's that
bad you don't have to feel your feelings
all the time but if you're feeling your
feelings never it's a problem we got a
problem and that might lead to Crystal
barbells flying right right uh but
ultimately those Crystal barbells if you
stay at it they turn into less and less
and less less Crystal barbells and then
suddenly you're not only feeling better
but you know how to communicate better
yeah uh but yeah you really gotta figure
not like you you want to like trick him
into this but like there has to be a way
for to get him to understand the price
he is paying by being a person that
doesn't open up he's paying a price
whether he knows it or not and it
somehow he must be illuminated to that
fact
you often talk like the guy the bad guy
from The Matrix I don't do that I don't
do that Illuminating like you do it but
it's okay also he should open up because
that stuff
becomes cancer later on for sure yeah
like you that's what I'm saying those
are one of the those are one of the
costs of not opening up you need to
release Crystal barbells also otherwise
that [ __ ] will and then becomes cancer
and you've got melanoma on your chest
dude try to get him to go to [ __ ]
better help he doesn't have to get off
of his couch yeah go to bed dude yeah
give him the code for better help for
our [ __ ]
um and it's really uh I don't know it's
it is weird though that there are still
guys that are like no way not therapy
that's for [ __ ] women or whatever the
[ __ ] you know it's for like people who
have real problems yeah yeah yeah yeah
let me tell you something Buddy
you probably got problems if you're not
adamantly against therapy yeah stripping
oh look at that look at that look at
that okay I guess it's been an hour
hasn't it yeah I guess it has but also
um yeah that's it sounds good
got lint all over me that's great but
dude that's the life uh the the the spin
move spin move mentality hoodie that you
can get on lifelinemerch.com and uh if
you want one-on-one advices sessions
with Matt he books them up they're
booked uh you know go to that video.com
you got to get in there uh and uh if you
have a question go to watch lifeline.com
another thing is your boy's gonna be in
Denver your boy's going to be in Albany
your boy's going to be in San Diego your
boy's going to be in New York your boy's
going to be in Chicago your boy's gonna
be in Springfield your boy's going to be
in [ __ ] Midland Texas your boy's
gonna be a lot of different places your
boys gonna be a Seattle your boy's gonna
be in Portland your boy's gonna be in
Lakeland your boy's gonna be in you know
what I mean your boys everywhere your
boys on the present yep my mom need
present so that's it man uh so come on
and see me on tour chrysalia.com and uh
that's that yay
hello
hello hello hello hello
[Music]